hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta emisión nos acompaña a
juliaca serán o ella es médica
internista especialista en adicciones y
en medicina canal y acá una de las
máximas referentes sobre este tema en
uruguay además es la presidenta de la
sociedad uruguaya de endocannabinoides
casera no muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
gracias a ustedes por la invitación
julia le propongo comenzar hablando de
por algunos mitos no en torno a la
marihuana porque como siempre no cuando
hay provisión y hay ocultamiento suelen
aparecer mitos o relatos que no siempre
están fundados verdad cuál cree usted
que son los principales uno si me
permite por ejemplo que se escucha mucho
es el de que la marihuana es la puerta
de entrada al consumo de otras
sustancias por ejemplo no
si eso es lo que se inicia en realidad
no es así nosotros trabajamos en
adicciones y vemos
lo que importa son los factores de
riesgo los factores de protección para
el consumo de sustancias no es con lo
que uno empieza y lo que se olvida la
gente que dice eso es que bueno que hay
que ir como a los orígenes que pasan en
la familia que pasa en ese grupo donde
se mueve la persona que consume no es
que los que consumen cannabis van a
terminar esté consumiendo cocaína u
otras sustancias o pasta base o heroína
ahora es la puerta para y además para
nosotros que usamos el canal y medicinal
muchas veces es puerta de salida del
consumo de otras sustancias y hablando
bueno hablábamos del cannabis en
medicinal se utiliza como estaba
diciendo entonces en terapias para otro
tipo de adicciones sin claro y funciona
a ver no todo el mundo acepta el
cannabis y sobre todo los que usan
consumen
drogas más duras pero si lo usamos lo
usamos para cocaína lo usamos para
alcohol para adictos a pasta base
también muy interesante
julia hablamos no del uso medicinal cuál
es su postura respecto del uso
recreativo del cannabis
bueno en general son las entrevistas
santiago siempre digo que no mezclo lo
que es el recreativo con el medicinal
porque la gente se complica pero
lo que sí pienso que los que son mayores
de 18 años que por que usen que consuman
sustancias que sean y que sepan lo que
están consumiendo porque cuál es el
problema el problema es los que tengan
altas cantidades de thc por más que los
que usen un recreativo busquen en un
término que se usa en los secuestros en
colombia colocarse la historia es este
bueno de eso cualquier producto que uno
es el que estoy el cannabis noria
acepción sepan cuál es la cantidad de
thc que usa y que no tenga y que son
cultivo que no tenga contaminada antes y
tóxicos
ahora galgos al uso medicinal julia
cuáles son los principales beneficios
que puede traer el uso medicinal del
cannabis
en realidad hay varios porque te ayuda
muchísimo a síntomas no y los que son
más conocidos es el analgésico el
antiepiléptico el hipnótico y ayuda al
contacto social disminuye la fobia
social lo que tiene que ver con la
ansiedad
va a depender que usemos va a depender
qué tipo de síntomas querramos tratar y
cómo vamos a ayudar en la gente con
cáncer se está estudiando el efecto
apostólico esto el que ataca las células
tumorales y respeta a las sanas es decir
hay una variedad de síntomas que podemos
tratar con el cannabis medicinal
ahora por otro lado julián la marihuana
crea usted que continúa siendo una
suerte de estigma para muchísimas
personas y de ser así porque a que lo
atribuye
a ver
el cannabis como la marihuana el
cannabis o lo decimos porque en realidad
que es lo mismo pero tiene como una
connotación más medicinal con un poco
para separar las cuestiones viene se usa
de muchísimo tiempo y tiene antecedentes
de uso medicinal de madeco nominal es
decir hay muchísima cosa pero cuál es el
problema hasta ahora hasta que se empezó
cómo hablar a regularizar hasta que se
decidió que el cbd el cannabidiol no
tenía efectos por la vez y por la merece
en realidad siempre se piensa que es una
sustancia de abuso y no se piensa que
puede ser también una un medicamento que
puede ser de uso medicinal entonces hay
como mucho tabú en todo lo que sea
consumo
de cannabis recreativo pero también está
en el que usa el cannabis medicinal el
miedo a que quizás eso le dé una
adicción y esto tiene que ver con que
los médicos no nos enseñaron que el
cannabis podría tener un uso medicinal
sino que nosotros los de mi generación
que ellos ya soy grande pero también
todavía los de ahora y esto pasa en
muchos países por lo que charlado este
si se sigue enseñando como sustancia de
abuso no se nos enseña como que puede
tener un quiste una respuesta en
patologías diversas en atacar a
distintos síntomas o sea que esa suerte
de estigmatización quizás también se
produce dentro del mismo ambiente de
médicos sí claro sí claro cada vez menos
por suerte en uruguay al menos de lo que
yo conozco por qué por qué tiene que ver
con lo que nos enseñan de dónde viene
tiene que ver con que esto no tiene
visitadores médicos que lo presenten
tiene que ver con poner el interés y
como uno puede ir sacando los prejuicios
en realidad por eso digo en uruguay en
la medida en que se regularizó en el
2013 después hubo un decreto que
regularizaba el cannabis medicinal
después hicimos desde el sindicato
médico y con las otras organizaciones en
este un curso para médicos empezó como a
ver otro movimiento pero todavía hay
gente que bueno piensa que es droga si
todas las sustancias media también se
aprueba lo primero que le va a dar
adicción que es o no que se le va a
complicar cuando empiezan a caer los
tabúes cuando los mismos pacientes que
mejoran y que el médico ve que realmente
ha cambiado empieza a preguntar qué pasó
y allí empiezan de las distintas
sociedades médicas a recurrir a la
sociedad endocannabinoide no salgo para
médico que trabajamos con cannabis
medicinal a decir bueno a ver quiero
saber qué es esto que está pasando
es bien interesante y que quisiera que
usted nos ayude a comprender lo mejor
que tiene que ver con que los distintos
productos de cannabis actúan en lo que
es el sistema endocannabinoide no del
organismo humano por un lado podría
explicarnos de la manera más simple
posible por favor qué es este sistema
endocannabinoide y si su existencia
significa o implica no que el cuerpo
humano está de cierta manera quizás
preparado de manera natural para el
consumo de cannabis
lo interesante es la pregunta de
santiago el sistema endocannabinoide es
parte de nuestro
de siempre del cuerpo humano digamos y
en algunos animales también por eso esta
terapia de cannabis medicinal se puede
hacer en perros por ejemplo
lo que se descubrió hace poco menos de
30 años que medicina es muy poco es un
sistema que regula la homeostasis del
organismo es decir cuando nos enfermamos
trata de liberar a su vez cannabinoides
los nuestros son endocannabinoides
quiere así que nosotros tenemos
cannabinoides propios como son la
anandamida y el dosaje cuando ese
equilibrio se rompe
digamos ahí es que podemos usar otros
cannabinoides externos como pueden ser
los fit o cannabinoides que son los de
las plantas o los cannabinoides
sintéticos que nosotros acá en uruguay
no tenemos pero en otros países hay si
estoy hablando de los sintéticos
medicinales
este sistema tiene receptores
tiene ligando cuando los nosotros que
están distribuidos en distintas partes
del organismo y de acuerdo a que el
cannabinoide nosotros le vemos cómo se
va a unir que va a estimular o que va a
disminuir esto qué quiere decir es como
un regulador de todo lo que pasa lo
interesante de este sistema a diferencia
de los otros sistemas que son
neurotransmisores se sintetiza demanda
en general en los otros sistemas hay
acopio producen hay acopio y cuando
precisan estar en este exterior que la
diferencia también después además de
otras cosas se sintetiza demanda decir
cuando el individuo precisa lo sintetiza
es como un poco básico pero como para
que la gente entienda que no es que
actúa porque si no se decía que era
bueno partes de la planta porque es de
la tierra que tiene buena energía no no
eso lo tiene pero en realidad actúa en
un sistema fisiológico que tiene función
como neurotransmisor y que actúa en los
otros sistemas es decir receptores hay
en todos lados
y lo interesante perdón porque esto es
importante también para la gente no hay
en él no hay receptores para el sistema
endocannabinoide el tronco encefálico y
esto hace la diferencia para la
analgesia es importante a diferencia de
lo triste amor fino sus derivados que
tienen receptores en el tronco
encefálico nyse bac se puede complicar
con la muerte esto hace que el cannabis
usar cannabis medicinal es seguro no va
a producir nunca las manos sino a
uruguay es un país que está a la
vanguardia en todo este tema a julia la
regulación legal del cannabis se aprobó
si mal no tengo entendido el año 2013 el
estado asumió el control la regulación
de la importación la exportación la
plantación la producción el
almacenamiento también la
comercialización la distribución del
cannabis y sus derivados
ahora le quisiera preguntarnos en base a
esto hay en el país algún registro o
tienen cifras sobre lo que fue el
consumo de cannabis durante esta
pandemia se incrementó
no es una pregunta el consumo de
cannabis recreativo preguntas atún dado
que como en estos días se estaban
sacando algunas publicaciones que decía
que si nosotros no tenemos esa misma
esa misma idea incluso después de la
regulación que uno de los problemas era
que esto iba a disparar el consumo de
cannabis que crea estamos hablando del
canal y recreativo se vio en distintas
investigaciones que no fue así y que no
trajo problemas ni la distribución en
farmacias ni lo que tiene que ver con
los cultivos este porque claro lo que se
decía era se hacía y como mucho más
oferta o está liberado este va a haber
más consumo no no no fue tan así y en
estos días es que se estaba hablando los
que saben del tema lo que están más más
en el tema de canarias recreativos
decían que el nivel de consumo había
sido el mismo
julia nos ha pasado rapidísimo la
entrevista quisiera decir del evento con
ustedes mucho tiempo más pero le vuelvo
a agradecer este tiempo con france24 a
simple hacer
las series mío y bueno y nos estamos
viendo así es y así será ojalá
muchísimas gracias una vez más y a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]